welcome to the Mana Recaps this is The
Flash season one meet Barry Allen the
brilliant mild-mannered CSI Tech when he
was a kid his mom was murdered by these
mysterious flashes of light and because
that's crazy of course his dad went away
for it so all these years he's secretly
been working to solve his mom's murder
and prove his dad's innocence Star Labs
is celebrating the launch of their new
particle accelerator created by the
genius Harrison Wells but something goes
wrong it explodes and that night Barry
struck by lightning and that was no
normal lightning bolt because Barry now
has boom yeah he's got super speed he
works with Star lab's team to figure out
his powers there's Cisco Ramon the funny
guy genius mechanical engineer Dr
Caitlin snow super nice biochem and of
course the man Harrison Wells himself
who's in a wheelchair now he was
paralyzed the night of the explosion so
with their help Barry figures out his
powers and he becomes the flash the
fastest man alive now Barry has a crush
on Iris West daughter of Detective Joe
West who took Barry in after his mom's
murder so basically Barry has a crush on
his stepsister no that's not weird she
has a boyfriend right now anyway this
hot cop Eddie but she wants to be a
journalist and she's real interested in
this new superhero they're calling the
streak so she starts up her own blog and
gives him the much better name of the
flash but Barry's not the only one who
got powers that night there's a whole
Rhodes gallery of one-off villains who
have powers depending on where they were
when the wave hit so with his science
team in his earpiece Barry figures out
ways to use his speed to take down all
sorts of meta-human threats hilariously
no matter the situation the solution is
always run faster among the infinite
one-off metahuman threats is Barry's
first Nemesis the non-metah human genius
criminal Leonard snart when he steals a
freeze ray that Cisco made he becomes
Captain Cold another Korean villain is
the giant genius Gorilla Grodd he shows
up once per season another big plot this
season is Caitlin snows fiance Robbie
who died the night of the particle
accelerator explosion but another
scientist who is there Dr Martin Stein
was holding a science thing and Robbie's
Essence got blown into him they combined
into one person with fire powers called
Firestorm but now the main villain of
season 1 is another Speedster he's all
in yellow and introduces himself as the
reverse flash now that Barry knows what
a Speedster is it's super obvious that
this is the guy who killed his mom as it
turns out Harrison Wells has a secret he
is the reverse flash turns out this
guy's not Harrison Wells at all his name
is IA Bard Thon The Flash is arch
nemesis from the future the real
Harrison Wells was a good guy but
earbard Don with some future tech oh
stole his identity he and the Flash
traveled back through time during one of
their standard Speedster fights it was
that night he killed Barry's mom but
when he went to leave oh his powers had
been drained he got trapped back in our
time I'm sorry Cisco I really do like
you you're like a son to me but I'm an
evil sociopath oh vibrating hand and all
Speedster through the heart elsewhere
that same day Barry tells Iris how he
feels about her and these two have their
passionate kiss but the metahuman threat
of the week is sending a tidal wave at
Central City and to stop at berries you
guessed it gotta run fast in fact he
runs so fast it's the first time he whoa
travels through time yes there's a lot
of time travel shenanigans on the show
we're just getting started so with his
knowledge of the future Barry catches
the weather wizard immediately changing
the course of the day Cisco never finds
out world's secret and this time when
Barry confesses his love for Iris the
whole Situation's different she's like
ew you're like my brother and I'm dating
someone not cool Barry soon though even
in this new timeline they start to
suspect Harrison Wells and the Gang
stumbles across his secret science man
cave Dave from the newspaper headline
Barry learns that in a few years he will
die in the crisis more on that later
sothon tells Barry the whole backstory
he told Cisco in the day that never
happened and it's like yo kid if you
open a time portal for me I'll go back
to my own time be out of your hair and
more than that you can use it to go back
to the night your mom was killed and
save her so Barry agrees and Thon
teaches him how to open a time portal
which is basically run real fast if you
run fast enough wow you enter the speed
force more on that later so poof fairy's
traveled back to his childhood home the
night his mom was killed his future self
is there fighting the reverse flash but
he sees our berry and he's like no don't
do it so he carries kidbury away and
Thon goes to stab his mom but Barry
trust his future self and lets it happen
but now Barry's back boom breaks the
time machine he figures since I didn't
get to save my mom our deal's off and
it's time for the final Speedster fight
the reverse flash is about to win when
oh a shot rings out but wait who was hit
it was Eddie who shot himself no Eddie
turns out Eddie's last name is Thon yeah
he is IA Bard's great-great-grandfather
athan's descendant when he's dead oh he
fade is out of existence but now for
science reasons the time portal
destabilizes and turns into a black hole
that threatens to suck up the whole
earth for more science reasons Barry can
close it but to do that he's gonna have
to you guessed it run really fast but to
fully close it he needs help from
Firestorm flies up there and defuses in
the middle of it boom yeah that worked
Dr Stein survives but unfortunately
Ronnie did not so sad for poor Caitlyn
he just got married at the end of last
season speaking of romance there's a new
hot girl cop on the force and she's
super into nerdy see his eye stuff long
story short she and Barry date for the
whole first half of the season but then
she goes back off to CSI College goodbye
turns out Joe West has a surprise son
named Wally he's a delinquent Street
racer but soon becomes part of the
family so life goes on in Central City
with a new one-off met a human attacking
every week but why have they never seen
these metahumans before Well turns out
they are from a parallel Earth they call
it Earth 2 one of a series of infinite
Earths and strap yourself in cause it's
Multiverse time this handsome man who
tells him about it is Jay Garrick he is
The Flash over on Earth too and his arch
nemesis there is a Speedster with blue
Lightning called Zoo the black hole they
cost at the end of season one opened a
portal between the worlds and Jay
Garrick got sucked in through it and now
Zoom is using smaller portals all over
the city to bring through Earth two
metahumans and have them attack the
flash one of the earth two metahumans is
a giant shark man what yes he's called
king shark and much like Gorilla Grodd
he shows up about once a season anyway
the guy who took down king shark is the
earth too Dr Harrison Wells much like
his real Earth Wind counterpart he's the
genius behind Star Labs but this one
carries a laser gun and he's real grumpy
it's weird having Dr Wells back on the
team so they call this guy Harry turns
out this Harrison Wells is working for
him because he has his daughter Jesse
hostage they forgive him though you were
just doing what you had to do to save
your daughter and now we're gonna help
you it's time for a bro road trip over
to Earth 2. but Earth 2 Firestorm is a
villain along with his girlfriend
Caitlin snow who on this Earth has crazy
ice powers she's killer frost she leads
them to zoom's dungeon where they rescue
Jesse and make it back to Earth one
gonna close the breach behind him but
not before Zoom oh
Eric through the art no in the meantime
Cisco starts having trippy Clairvoyant
visions of what's going on elsewhere or
in the future he built some sweet Shades
to help him Focus his power and he goes
by the name Vibe Cisco tries to Vibe J
but turns out Jay is zoom he has two
seasons in a row the villain was one of
their friends in Disguise turns out his
real name is Hunter zolomon he was a
serial killer on Earth too that got the
flash Powers he started playing both
villain and hero just for fun and to
mess with people but wait a minute who
is the Jay Garrick he killed well that
was a time remnant of himself he created
by going back just a little bit so he
could be on earth two and one at the
same time so last season they defeated
the reverse flash and then the time he
spent mentoring Barry he came to like
him a little bit he especially felt bad
about his father in prison so he left a
will as Harrison Wells confessing to the
murder of Barry's mom so yes it happens
Barry's dad is out of jail their
celebration is short-lived however when
Zoom crashes the party no don't do it
but Zoom does oh kills Barry's father
super complicated reasons instead of a
fight it comes down to a race and so
boom they're racing around this big
science thing which turns out with two
speedsters powering it up would destroy
all the other Earths and the Multiverse
so to stop it Barry's got to use one of
zoom's tricks and create a Time remnant
of himself while one of them fights Zoom
the other one runs around the science
thing real fast sacrificing himself but
saving the Multiverse and the surviving
Berry defeats Zoom so the day is saved
so wait a minute Barry what's the deal
with your time Remnant you're telling me
that the future you came back in time
then sacrificed himself Barry's like hey
don't worry about it hopefully it won't
come back to haunt me later for now
though they rescue the mystery Man in
the Iron Mask and turns out it is a
doppelganger of Barry's father yes this
is the real Jay Garrick who is the Flash
on Earth three so the day is saved and
everyone's going back to their own Earth
team flash is an expert in this
Multiverse stuff now Barry though is
still super sad about his dad's death so
he decides to do some time travel back
to the night his mother was murdered and
this time consequences be damned he
busts in there and saves her and it
works now in the present both of his
parents are alive and well great success
but the world's different in some other
ways Barry Allen never became the flash
here it's actually Wally West who got
flash Powers going by Kid Flash the
biggest change though without his
mother's death Barry never went to live
with the West so he never met Iris he
has to orchestrate to meet cute so they
can start dating but as that's happening
he's starting to lose memories of his
previous life he goes to see the reverse
flash eobardan who's got locked in a
cage and he names his alternate timeline
Flashpoint he's like yeah kid time
travel is messy pretty soon you'll
forget your old life entirely and you'll
lose your power so Barry has no choice
but to run him back to the past and let
him kill his mom so back in the real
present day everything's normal again
except is it those Caitlyn has the ice
powers of her Earth 2 doppelganger
killer frost it seems like a split
personality thing sometimes Killer Frost
takes over and goes full super villain
Gene Cisco face off about a dozen times
he's always like Caitlin I know you're
in there and she's always like no I'm
not and soberry has to accept things are
stuck the way they are now in this post
Flashpoint timeline but some of the
people who are meta-human villains in
the flashpoint timeline are having
memories of that alternate life they're
being summoned by this creepy cultist
plague doctor guy who calls himself
Alchemy and can somehow give them their
Flashpoint powers and so per usual
there's a whole series of one-off
villains of the week one day Earth two
Harrison Wells comes for a visit with
his daughter Jesse who's now a Speedster
she trains with the Flash and goes by
the superhero named Jesse quick pretty
soon though her and her dad are going
home to Earth too but he doesn't want to
leave team Flash without Harrison Wells
so they hold auditions from the whole
Multiverse of Wells some of who look
hilarious if anyone know who seems like
a great fit so Cisco Vibes him on over
and H.R Wells joins the team Harry was a
very grumpy Wells but HR is extremely
friendly real nice guy but pretty soon
it becomes apparent he has no idea about
any of the science stuff one day while
the West starts having memories of when
he was Kid Flash over in Flashpoint he
goes to see Alchemy but turns out
Alchemy was just the hype man the real
big bad is a Speedster with white
lightning oh he's a crazy robot
Transformer guy yes he calls himself
savitar the god of speed as usual with a
new Speedster Bill and he's way faster
than Barry but can't just kill him right
now for complicated super villain
reasons but that temporarily blasts
Barry a few months into the future where
he sees himself facing off with savitar
who has Iris and no he kills her so now
the main goal is to alter that future
and save iris's life another change from
Flashpoint is that Barry has a partner
at the CSI lab it's Julian Albert a
meta-human specialist who does not get
along with Barry eventually The Flash
takes Alchemy down and turns out Alchemy
is Julian he's not evil though he has no
memory of it turns out he found that
Philosopher's Stone and oh it possessed
him by the way while he couldn't resist
he touches alchemy's philosopher's stone
boom Wally's got Speedster Powers
officially joins team flash as Kid Flash
romance blooms between our new
speedsters Jesse and Wally and Papa Joe
West has a new girlfriend district
attorney Cecile Horton Barry and Iris
have their actual first kiss this time
it's number three for him but the others
got erased and from here on out Barry
and Iris are dating for real Barry and
Iris put their relationship on super
speed they move in together then he
proposes but they have a big fight but
then there's a musical episode with
Supergirl then he proposes again while
singing the best romance though is
between Cisco and Gypsy and
interdimensional Bounty Hunter yeah
she's got by Powers too and of course
you can't have a season of Flash without
Gorilla Grodd last season they sent him
to the Earth 2 Gorilla City now he
tricked Barry into fighting his gorilla
rival so Grodd can be king and Lead an
army of gorillas on Central City now
back to savitar sabotage not a robot
he's a man in a suit and pretty soon
Barry Allen finds out who's inside it is
himself yes few future evil Barry Allen
turns out this guy is a Time Remnant
Berry created to help him fight savitar
but when he survived everyone shunned
him because it was weird and now he
became savitar Cisco goes to the time
travel explanation board to try to
explain it but it's still super
confusing and so finally the day has
come savitar captures Iris and so here
we are we failed to change anything and
a hoe Iris
no
no yes earlier he sneakily disguised
himself as Iris didn't tell Barry so
savitar wouldn't know and so HR Wells
sacrificed himself to save the future
and so it's the final showdown while the
speedsters all run around Cisco and
Killer Frost having their final battle
and so when savitar grabs I'm gonna kill
Cisco oh blasted with frost power yeah
Caitlyn was still in there in the end
though good Barry Allen oh phases into
the savitar suit kicks the other one out
he blasts that thing apart like yo man
you're done savitar goes for a final
sneak attack but oh shot by Iris West
and evil berries erased from the
timeline and now the day is saved or is
it because there's a crazy lightning
storm going on yes with the speed force
prison unoccupied it's unstable gonna
destroy the Multiverse so Barry says his
goodbyes he thinks he's going away
forever and he walks into the speed
force that's how season three of The
Flash comes to an end with the flash
gone it's up to our backup Heroes to
defend Central City especially Wally
West who's now leading team Kid Flash
one day though they figure it's time to
do some science stuff and bring Barry
Allen back it doesn't seem to work
though because the portal opened up
across town and coming out of it is
naked bearded Barry Allen but when the
portal opened up it showered everyone on
the bus with dark matter and yes it's
created a whole new series of one-off
meta human villains of the week the boss
matters to help them face these new
threats team flash needs a Harrison
Wells and this season it's the same
grumpy Earth 2 Harry Wells from season 2
who steps right back into his well-paid
relationship with Cisco Cisco's still
dating Gypsy the interdimensional Bounty
Hunter but cross Earth long distance is
really tough and even though they still
love each other they call it quits
things are going great though with
Captain Joe West and D.A Cecile Horton
in fact she's pregnant so Papa Joe's
gonna be a papa again and for fake
science reasons becoming pregnant has
unlocked cecile's latent meta-human
Powers she can read minds now now what
about Dr Caitlin snow who left team
flash at the end of last season she's
been dealing with her killer frost
alternate ego who she hulks out into
sometimes pretty soon though Caitlyn's
friends convince killer frost they're
her friends too so they consider to
rejoin team flash now one of the bus
metas is Ralph dibney private
investigator who ends up with stretchy
Powers so soon he joins team flash as
the elongated man which kind of sounds
more like a porn actor than a superhero
now remember Barry and Iris got engaged
last season and it's time for the
wedding but it's rudely interrupted by
their evil Nazi doppelgangers From
Another Earth yes this big crossover
this season crisis on Earth X and long
story short at the end of it Barry and
Iris do get married in a joint wedding
with Oliver and Felicity from Arrow but
now for the main plot turns out pulling
the strings behind the scenes is this
evil Professor X looking guy called The
Thinker he created a thinking cap to
make him smarter and on the night of the
particle accelerator explosion it
blasted his brain with dark matter
turned him into a Super Genius but
unfortunately his body is dying that's
why he's got to sit in the creepy sci-fi
wheelchair The Thinker captures one of
the bus metas whose telepathic Powers
let him steal his body but Devoe dumped
his original body in Barry Allen's
apartment made it look like he killed
him and yeah Barry Allen's going to jail
he has to team up with the other bus
metas he's captured so far and together
they escape but that's exactly what Devo
wanted because now he flies in and takes
all their powers until finally he
captures the final boss meta Ralph dibny
yes Ralph stretchy cells can handle his
super brain and as an added bonus he can
transform back to his original
appearance and now Devoe the thinker
with all of the bus meta Powers has his
own epic Darth Vader Rogue one hallway
moment his evil master plan is to launch
the satellites into orbit and use them
to take away everyone on Earth's
intelligence and rule the world as the
only smart person turns out the key is
D.A Cecile Horton's new telepathic
Powers with them she's able to send
Barry into devoe's mind there he finds
the mind of Ralph dibne he's still alive
and if they can escape the thinkers
defeated Ralph's got his body back with
davogan they're able to stop the
enlightenment but he left one more trap
for them he's sending the satellite
crashing into Earth and so the flash has
to stop a falling satellite the only way
he knows how by running really fast and
punching it in the face but wait what's
this time freezes and reverses someone
time traveled but it wasn't buried this
time it was a mystery Speedster with
purple and gold lightning who goes up
and helps double punch it boom satellite
exploded and the day is saved Joe and
Cecile have their baby and as the whole
team celebrating this random new girl
comes to the door she is Nora West Allen
yes Barry and iris's daughter from the
future as far as the time travel
Shenanigans go on the show it's pretty
standard stuff yes Nora is also a
Speedster goes by the name XS pretty
soon though Barry gets her trained up
and she's capturing metahuman villains
but what's this oh this one is killed
this new villain is called cicada
because of the rattling sound his
breathing mask makes he controls a
wicked lightning bolt-shaped knife that
dampens many human powers and without
their powers team flash is useless
against him so to help them catch this
killer team flash needs uh Harrison
Wells there's many in the Multiverse
that aren't helpful right now but one of
them is a master detective in fact he
goes by his middle name Sherlock they
soon discover that on the night of the
Enlightenment charged from Devoe
satellite hit various pieces of
Technology infusing them with dark
matter turning them into meta Tech and
so once again the various villains of
the week were accidentally created by
team flash this is where cicada's dagger
came from too that Nike and his niece
got blown up the dagger landed in his
chest making him a metahume infused with
it his niece Grace got hit too she's in
a coma now and he's vowed to kill all
meta-humans to take Vengeance Cisco
Ramone spends the first half of the
Season moping over his recent breakup
with Gypsy in the end though the best
way to get over your ex is to meet
someone new it's this cute photographer
bartender Camilla they hit it off and by
the end of the season they're going
steady now remember last season the
Thinker took away Caitlin snows killer
frost powers and turns out her powers
didn't come from the particle
accelerator explosion Killer Frost has
been a part of her since childhood long
story short Caitlyn tracks down her
father who also has an evil icy split
personality and this one unfortunately
has taken full control of them so to
save her friends Caitlyn's got it oh ice
blast yeah killer frost is back and of
course one day Gorilla Grodd is back
here to conquer Central City again this
time to stop him they gotta bring in
another giant animal it's king shark
meanwhile cicada is still out there
killing metahumans now the flash can't
beat this guy with speed alone so he has
to use his real superpower emotional
heart to hearts that convince villains
to find the goodness within oh talk new
Jitsu my only weakness but who's this
busting in it's another cicada turns out
it is his grown-up niece Grace from the
future she's like hey Uncle I came back
from the future to help continue our
mission kill all meta humans but he's
like yo Gracie I was wrong this isn't
the life I want for you but oh she kills
him she is too far gone now this whole
time Sherlock has been suspicious of
Nora indeed this whole time she's been
communicating with someone in the future
and eventually Sherlock discovers her
secret it is none other than the reverse
flash eobard Thon for complicated time
travel reasons still alive and wearing
the face of Harrison Wells they became
kind of friends he taught her how to
time travel so she could go meet her dad
and later when she learned Thon killed
her grandma he's like hey I feel bad
about that I'm a change man now now the
team found a mirror gun the only thing
that would destroy cicada stagger but
it's Ralph who figures out thon's master
plan see the thing dampening his power
in the future is cicada's dagger this
whole time he's been manipulating Nora
to go back there so they can destroy it
but the flash has no choice he's got to
mirror gun the dagger boom evil dagger
destroyed removing evil Grace from the
timeline unfortunately this means the
daggers are raced from the future and
just before his execution thon's got his
powers back because they figured out his
plan the good guys run here to stop him
and they have a little Speedster Chase
for a while eventually thon's captured
but wait what's happening to Nora all
the shenanigans has changed the timeline
too much this version of adult Nora is
the race from the timeline and with all
these changes to the timeline the crisis
that flash disappears in is coming
sooner and now it's finally here the
mega crossover all these CW shows have
been leading to crisis on infinite
Earths long story short the wave of
antimatter energy is destroying the
entire Multiverse so all our heroes come
together to stop it but anyway this is
it to save the Multiverse Barry's gotta
sacrifice himself of course though old
flash immediately figures out the
obvious loophole and so nice takes one
for the team and sacrifices himself to
save the Multiverse turns out though
that was totally pointless the
Multiverse is destroyed anyway a select
few Heroes traveled to the dawn of time
to face down the anti-monitor it's a big
CGI battle anti-monitor 1v1's the Green
Arrow Oliver Queen who long story short
defeats him but dies somehow though his
sacrifice restarted the universe but not
a Multiverse it's been condensed into
one Earth Prime now back to normal
Shenanigans YouTuber scientist Chester P
rank accidentally turned himself into a
black hole so the flash has to stop a
black hole the only way he knows how by
running really fast and punching it in
the face somehow this actually works and
Chester has to cool off for a while but
by the end of the season he joins team
flash as a Science Guy now you can't
have a season of The Flash without a
Harrison Wells this season it's an
Indiana Jones Adventurer a type who
calls himself Nash and of course one
episode Gorilla Grodd comes back but to
this season he claims he feels bad about
being a villain so he and Flash team up
to escape his mental prison maybe Gratz
a good guy now now the main villain of
the first half of the season is Dr
Ramsay Rosso he's got the blood cancer
and tries to cure it with dark matter
which as you might expect does not go
well I don't want to use the term
vampire but he does go around sucking
out everyone's blood but the flash takes
them out the only way he knows how by
running real fast and punching him in
the face now the main plot this season
begins with Allegra Garcia a young meta
human with ultraviolet light Powers
she's wanted for murder and D.A Cecile
Horton's Prosecuting her but with her
new mind reading powers she knows
Allegra is innocent turns out the killer
was her evil cousin Esperanza who got
the same powers and is now a metahuman
assassin turns out they're dealing with
a super secret criminal organization
called black hole who employs a bunch of
like themed assassins the investigation
leads them to McCulloch Technologies and
the leader of black hole is their CEO
Joseph Carver one night iris is snooping
around his dead wife Eva mcculloch's old
office she finds a mysterious mirror and
oh what's this oh pulled into it and no
one knows iris is missing because mirror
Iris has taken over her life and the
Flash is losing his speed because the
speed force died but if anyone can
figure out how to build an artificial
speed force it's Harrison Wells remember
since crisis Nashville's the Indiana
Jones type is the only Wells left but
all the other Wells are in his head so
working together they figure it out and
turns out to make it work they're gonna
have to sacrifice themselves oh run
Berry run Flash gotta speed back long
story short he figures out how to get
Iris out of the mirror verse but then
she realizes she's gotta put her love
into that speed force so now Barry super
speed is literally powered by his and
iris's love anyway mirror lady has some
dastardly planned to replace all of
Central City with mirror clones
flashbust into fighter but he ends up
defeating her with his real superpower
emotional heart to hearts that convince
villains to become good guys now it's
not just Harrison Wells leaving team
flash this season Ralph dibny the
elongated Man is leaving too and Cisco
Ramon get more serious with his
girlfriend Camilla in fact they decide
that they want to leave Central City but
he's been training his replacement
Chester P Ronk who we met last season he
now officially takes over as team
flashes Tech guy and he brings with him
his own Cool vibe then team flash gets
another new member kind of because
Killer Frost and Caitlyn separate bodies
I can't even begin to explain the
science of why this happens but in any
case Frost and Caitlyn no longer sharing
a body but still sharing an apartment in
fact Central City has a new ice power to
villain it's this bartender who goes by
chill blame and while he has cold Powers
he is super hot Frost has a huge lady
boner for him going back to the night
when Iris put her love into the
artificial speed force There Was An
Unexpected consequence turns out that
brought the real speed force back to
life but it also created other forces of
nature that are bad this hulked out High
School wrestler is the strength Force
they call Forza there's a fear force
that makes you scared they call psych
and there's a Time Force who they just
call Dion Because that's his name these
were all real people that now have these
Powers so Barry time travels back to
stop them from being created in the
first place but now that he's here he
realizes that because they were created
out of his and iris's love they're kind
of like his children it turns out Barry
is pro-life he decides to let them be
born so Barry wants to help his kids but
the speed force decides they're too
dangerous oh attacks him yeah the evil
speed force is the villain so it's a
Family Feud as the forces join forces
against their evil sister in a nonsense
CGI battle but in the end they defeat
her with their real superpower a
heart-to-heart speech that convinces her
to be a good guy again so with all this
talk about their children iris is like
hey why don't we make make some kids for
real oh Barry and Iris getting it on and
speedsters have a built-in pregnancy
test because your grown-up kid from the
future will time travel back to be like
congrats you knocked mom up yes Nora
excess is back but she's got a surprise
this time because in this new timeline
Barry and Iris have two kids she's got a
younger Speedster brother Bart but also
traveling back from the future is their
villain godspeed but what's this some
more godspeeds show up and then fight
the other godspeeds yeah there's a
godspeed Civil War they capture one of
them who explains why it's happening but
it's complete nonsense I didn't
understand it but the flash has to stop
it because if they keep doing bad slow
karate at each other they're gonna tear
this city apart eventually they track
down the real godspeed but he's got
amnesia so they send a Barry inside his
head to talk to him where he meets the
real real godspeed but he was not born
with the speed it's artificial he came
from the velocity X formula and so Barry
has no choice he gives the villain
exactly what he wants and oh the real
bull godspeed is Born Again sucks all of
his clone robots into himself so now
godspeed's gonna kill the flash but oh
who's this coming in the reverse flashy
a barred Thon he's like what's up Barry
I'm not gonna let this guy kill you I
have to kill you myself so for now
they're gonna team up so for their final
battle godspeed pulls a new move and
turns his Speedster lightning into a
sword yeah it's lightsaber time I mean
yeah just why not in the end Darth
godspeed's gonna win the Tao stabbed by
reverse flash so godspeed was the big
bad villain for all of three episodes
season eight begins with the Armageddon
crossover event although it's not much
of a crossover because the arrowverse is
basically done the villain is despero an
English soccer hooligan from the future
whose real form is a giant Pink alien
but he's not here to cause Armageddon
he's here to stop it by killing the
flash because turns out it's the flash
who goes crazy and destroys the world so
Barry travels to the Future to see how
Armageddon happens turns out this is all
the doing of Barry's arch nemesis eobard
Thon the reverse flash he's altered the
timeline to create his own perfect world
where he is The Flash and Barry Allen is
his villain a reverse flash it turns out
the secret to resetting the timeline is
you guessed it run really fast so fast
in fact it would destroy the world yeah
this is how Barry causes Armageddon but
with the Power of iris's Love he's able
to run fast enough to outrun Armageddon
and the day is saved the reverse flash
has followed him here but now he's being
erased from the timeline and instead of
letting that happen Barry decides to
save him by taking away his speed which
he is none too pleased about and swears
his Vengeance so with Armageddon over
the flash gets back to his usual Antics
the theme of the season is that team
flash is all leveled up like Barry so
fast now one-off villains of the week
like this are not even a threat anymore
his wife Iris has leveled up too the
Central City citizen is super successful
Dr Caitlin snow remember now has a
separate body from her Alter Ego Frost
and things are heating up between Frost
and chill Blaine which Caitlyn does not
approve of in the future Barry and Iris
is grown-up kids Nora and Bart get up to
Shenanigans they travel to our time for
a minor timeline fix but instead Bart
meets a hot scientist and they start
dating Papa Joe West is happily retired
from the new police chief is Kristen
Kramer who found out last season she's a
meta too who can temporarily borrow the
powers from nearby Meadows Barry finally
trusts her enough to reveal he's the
flash but she's like yeah man I mean
it's super obvious now there's a new
villain in town it's some super scary
smoke it does kill people though but not
with hot fire with cold fusion to
Caitlyn's note appears as her dead
fiance Ronnie but it's obviously not him
but turns out it actually is him but
turns out it's actually not him it was
just using his body for science reasons
his real identity is just a sentient
Cold Fusion Monster Called Death Storm
the secret to defeating him is for frost
to level up and get her own cold fusion
Powers now she's hell Frost and she's
able to eat this guy but what's this the
power overloads her and frost dies but
Caitlyn's resolved to save her sister
she turns her apartment into a secret
science lab and recruits chill Blaine to
bring Frost back does it work we'll find
out meanwhile there's a new Speedster in
Central City but it's a good guy it's Dr
Mina Dawan she's built a super Advanced
artificial speed Giver but turns out her
partner is the eobard Thon finally
wearing his own face but this version of
him really is a good guy the evil
Harrison Wellston is still locked up
with no speed but good thought didn't
know his machine accidentally Taps into
the negative speed force which turns
Mina into a villain luckily he and Mina
have a romance go and so with the Power
of Love she's not evil and she gets to
be a good guy Speedster named Fast Track
meanwhile Iris has caught a Time
sickness and now that's freed the evil
negative forces these two do the
standard move of running around
uselessly while Barry does a standard
move of running real fast and throwing a
lightning bolt but this was the negative
forces plan all along as they teleport
Iris here and oh it's too late to stop
it Barry kills Iris but she doesn't die
she turns into green dust and goes into
good thawn and for reasons I can't even
begin to explain he's transformed into
evil Harrison Wells Thon the negative
forces make him their Avatar and he gets
a huge power boost and a super cool new
suit Iris meanwhile doesn't die she's
hanging out with Damien dark inside his
time Stone and he tells her the secret
of how to just decide not to be dead
anymore Cecile by the way has leveled up
her own powers this season in fact she's
able to talk with the good forces and
put on the mask which somehow brings
them back the positive forces make Barry
their Avatar so Barry and Thon have
their final classic Speedster battle in
the end though Barry realizes the only
way to win is not to fight Thon goes the
other way with it tries to destroy the
whole universe but it's too much power
and Dao he's exploded erased from the
timeline again for good this time the
negative forces were beaten but not
defeated in the future they're choosing
a new Avatar but no matter how many
times they come back team flash will be
ready to stop him well at least one more
time because season 9 is finally the
final season and that's where the flash
season 8 comes to an end
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]